[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
you
you
shindeki sanzang go hakanaku gon die
hakuna die
arcadia ho na da na ganja type okay
cierto hence a higher be honesty
samastah romero power connection are
similar Timon one kind of support
cognitive season
Simone ha ha ha - Tonino great general
see
nets no sons like that
[Music]
so you know target the honey
does it occur uhok I said Angelica in
Boca Homolka okay - Mira que no se hi
Mets not oboz' daughter boqueron is aa
takara customer I know yoga shooters
they all got their nets no kata
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Komiyama Morecambe a note on economy
okay dinara homo de given autonomy Tyco
tuatara hoods are nomads so horizontal
Bethenny hi Selena apparel
[Music]
that's it
[Music]
hello say hi Joseph dipsticks
Neos tuna or annoy your committee ah
come on it's done
Mozilla ricotta
when we launch Nintendo switch our
vision was a home system you could play
together anytime anywhere two detachable
jaikon controllers countless play
possibilities from day one all of you
have shown the world what that means
when they're playing at home or on the
go from low to on high where will
Nintendo switch take you next to a
smashing Invitational cheered by fans
and challengers or on a journey through
verdant fields and Viridian cities in a
timeless quest to catch them all
you
a few weeks ago we showed you Pokemon
let's go Pikachu and Pokemon let's go
Eevee a grand new Pokemon adventure
through the vibrant Kanto region or your
partner Pikachu or Eevee is always by
your side add the transformative power
of Nintendo switch and you can play as
you like anywhere you like or for the
first time in this series catch your
battle Pokemon on one system with a
friend you can even transfer a Pokemon
into the game from Pokemon go
this
a poker ball plus you can use it like a
joy con controller with Pokemon let's go
Pikachu and let's go Eevee or play the
entire game with it alone you can put a
Pokemon into the pokeball plus then
bring it with you
sounds like there's already one inside
its the mythical Pokemon mu mu comes
exclusive with every poke of all plus
and can join you on your journey through
the game Pokemon let's go Pikachu
pokémon let's go Eevee
and the pokeball plus will be available
on November 16th discover new friends
and challenges as you explore this
mysterious and enchanting world wherever
you go with whoever you like only on
Nintendo switch now let's check out
something else we can't wait to show you
all right
[Music]
we've got to change it up though that's
gonna go too fast he's doing the same
we need to have like some angles are you
guys ready to do this fast inside
alright ready yes
[Music]
what was that
[Music]
three-two-one
[Music]
long ago the divine serous received a
revelation from the goddess a gift to
help guide the lost now the goddess
watches over fallen from her kingdom
above as the mother of our life the
arbiter every soul
[Music]
go ahead give me orders it's time to
measure your work as an instructor
[Music]
such a brutal irrational world we live
in
some believe the crests tokens of a
goddesses power are necessary to
maintain order but they're wrong
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
reach for my hand have sore away
here in Sharon
do you dare to walk this path with me
one misstep and we fall to our ruin so
take your first step I will return here
someday my teacher
promise me that you won't forget me
[Music]
I can't wait to drop off the battle bus
and meet some of you on the battlefield
in fortnight and on Nintendo switch you
can have the complete battle royale
experience whether playing together
online with friends in the same room or
around the world available at 10 a.m.
Pacific time today
Nintendo switch a home console where you
can access a full range of games content
including a wealth of groundbreaking
games from our independent development
community your support for indie games
on Nintendo switch has been inspiring
and to all of you as well as all of the
developers behind these rich and varied
experiences from all of us here at
Nintendo thank you
let's pull back the curtain on a few
more including two we're showing for the
first time here today aspiring chefs
ready your cleavers pots and cutting
boards in overcooked - a sequel that's
brimming with more recipes characters
kitchens and white-knuckle mayhem
prepare for the ultimate cook-off with
new features like the ability to throw
ingredients kitchens that can change on
the fly and with Nintendo switch the
opportunity to bake barbecue or broiled
with another player in Wireless local
and online player save the world from
clumsy cooking when team 17s frantic
food juggler arrives on August 7th hop
on a snail Ford berries or wipe out the
enemy's Queen to claim victory in Killer
Queen black redesign from the ground up
liquid bit and bumble bear games
acclaimed arcade extravaganza that
became a multiplayer phenomenon is
coming to Nintendo swish and for the
first time on console two teams of up to
four each and square off and exciting
battles play first on Nintendo switch
later this year and finally venture
through the mysterious subterranean
landscapes of a vast forgotten Kingdom
in Team cherries hollow Knight an action
adventure filled with gripping
bat and hunting secrets hand-drawn
characters and sublime scenery abound in
this sweeping platformer that offers
endless hours of intricate exploration
we revealed earlier this year that Halle
Knight was coming to Nintendo's switch
and I'm pleased to announce that the
game packed with all the previous
downloadable content is available on the
Nintendo eShop starting today
these are just a few of the terrific
indie games you can play in the months
ahead after this presentation
stay tuned for Nintendo treehouse live
streaming right from the e3 show floor
where our Nintendo game experts will
give you a closer look at some of these
games and more and I personally cannot
wait to watch as intrepid challengers
test their mettle in our splatoon 2
World Championship and Super Smash
Brothers Invitational 2018 the action
starts immediately following Nintendo
treehouse life before we move on I have
an important update on a game I know
fans have been looking forward to
cocteau path traveller from Square Enix
is coming exclusively for Nintendo
switch on July 13th and you can download
a brand new demo for the game from the
Nintendo eShop on June 14th now let's
take another action-packed look at some
more experiences coming soon to Nintendo
switch
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hi everyone I'm Shinya Takahashi of
Nintendo I hope you enjoyed what you've
seen recently it's been nice to see
people pull their Nintendo switch
systems from their bags to play even
when they have only a little bit of free
time so every time I see that I can't
help but smile
at Nintendo we approach development with
the goal of delivering new and unique
games to surprise people all over the
world and we're thankful for the many
publishing partners also making games
for Nintendo switch today we shared just
a small portion of what we're currently
working on we hope you will look forward
to what's coming next on Nintendo switch
take the site suck it now it's time to
share information on a certain title
I'll turn it over to someone I think you
know total [ __ ] i i'm Masahiro
Sakurai from Sora limited today I'd like
to introduce you to the new Super Smash
Brothers game for the Nintendo switch as
you may know Super Smash Brothers is an
action game about smashing beloved game
characters off the screen
many fighters have appeared in this
series I'm sure you're all eager to find
out who will be joining the roster this
time so we made a video to showcase some
fighters appearing in the game
the number next to each fighter
signifies the order in which they joined
the Super Smash Brothers series
please take a look
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what
that's right every fighter in Super
Smash Brothers history is joining the
battle indeed absolutely every Super
Smash Brothers fighter ever is in this
game whether they were originally DLC or
only appeared once in the past we
believe that's what players want so we
made the impossible possible any way you
slice it this one has the most smash for
your bucket simply put this is the
biggest crossover in gaming history once
again worlds will collide even so you're
starting roster may be as small as the
original Nintendo 64 game we've
streamlined the conditions for unlocking
fighters and we want to make the process
interesting so it feels like you're
constantly recruiting popular characters
to your side
[Music]
each their battles are also making a
return
see what happens when you hit many
different fighters against one another
now let's take a closer look at certain
fighters by highlighting how they've
changed since their last appearance
Mario's still easy-to-use but we did add
a little something for someone from his
latest adventure he can also wear his
wedding and builder outfits
[Music]
Lync Dawn's as champions tunic from The
Legend of Zelda breath of the wild his
bombs are now remotely detonated and his
final smash unleashes ancient arrows he
can also wear least familiar tunic of
the wild although it's been a while
the two-in-one fighter the ice climbers
are back work together with Nana once
she's gone you're in serious trouble
the Ike's outfit from Fire Emblem 1/2 of
radiance returns along with his look
from Fire Emblem radiant dawn now you
can use both versions for the first time
the two different versions are even
voiced a little differently prepare
yourself prepare yourself
[Music]
we now have the female version of
Pikachu complete with a heart-shaped
tail did you notice Pikachu Libre is a
girl Fox's design is now based on Star
Fox zero in his final smash has received
an overhaul this time final smashes are
straight to the point so you can get
right back to fighting
barkos final smash features an
unorthodox ship formations that's more
unruly than Fox's either way if the
landmaster has been retired
in one-on-one fights em you will always
faces opponents just like in his
original game appearances
it's a small touch that reduces
accidental command in boots charge moves
like samus's charge shot can now power
up in midair
you can cancel with jump or dodge but
you'll be open to attacks
Marth's dancing blade is faster and it's
easier to unleash one after another this
holds true for Roy and Lucena too in
addition Marth is now fully voiced in
English keep your eyes open
[Music]
back by popular demand veteran fighter
snake is sneaking back into the fray
it's been ten years since his last
appearance in the series so we can
finally make some new dream matches come
true
of course Shadow Moses Island is back to
King DDD's final smash is basically a
cage fight where he unleashes missiles
and a jet hammer
Picchu is also returning from super
smash brothers mail in its electric
shock still damaged self - so be careful
in the Legend of Zelda breath of the
wild Zelda's more into research than
fighting so her design is from The
Legend of Zelda a link between worlds
Zelda is much more elegant and regal
than our other fighters but we made sure
you wouldn't underestimate her energetic
attacks her final smash is a sealing
move called Triforce of wisdom
Sonic's final smash supersonic is more
souped up than ever
either here too slow or he's lightning
fast
pac-man also got a speed boost this time
around looping around the stage is just
like pac-man Georgia thing here Pokemon
trainers back with squirtle
Ivysaur and Charizard you can change
Pokemon during battle and this time
there's no penalty for sticking with one
so feel free to pick your main
also you can play as a female trainer
for the first time
some fighters like Captain Falcon
trigger a dramatic slo-mo effect on
strong attacks in one-on-one fights and
of course is hazardous big news stations
making a return
just like before you can play as cloud
in his Final Fantasy 7 costume or his
Final Fantasy 7 Advent Children costume
now you can see his limit gauge near his
damage percentage at all times special
displays are available for certain other
fighters too for example you can see how
much longer Robin can use Levin sword
and tones per villager we made it easier
to see what you pocketed
between the male and female versions
there are eight different villagers
Bowser's final smash Giga Bowser is even
bigger and better
he's now as big as Bowser from the
Yoshi's Island game all of mr. Gaiman
watches moves are back and he looks even
more like a geek in his original games
his transformations are more full of
character than ever young link from
super smash brothers melee is making a
comeback that makes three links for the
first time Lon Lon milk anyone
after 10 long years wolf makes his
return his design is based on Starbucks
zero and each of his moves have received
a significant other grade
[Music]
Kirby is his usual puffy self but we've
added a little something to his own
ability he has a copy ability for every
fighter so the more fighters we have the
more challenging he becomes to develop
[Music]
Shope used to require repeated button
presses to toggle minato arms but now
you can choose a specific one with a
button press and a quick directional
tilt sure is handy to change Artbox
lives we also added fiora to his final
smash
ganondorf rises again returning to his
popular design in the Legend of Zelda
Ocarina of Time and for his final smash
he becomes demon king again me fighters
proportions have been tweaked a bit
there are three types brawler sword
fighter and gunner the move set for each
type has also been enhanced you can now
choose from twelve oice options we're
hoping to get this fighter ready for
online play
previously Pitt's final smashes three
sacred treasures this time he'll be
riding in style like Eternia
in the last game zero suit samus is
final smash called in her gunship this
time she uses her power suit to fire a
devastating laser
when Alomar gets damaged you'll see a
crack in his helmet but don't worry
it'll get fixed up right away
[Music]
bayonetta's costumes from her first two
games are both available listen closely
and you'll hear differences in samba
it seems we have a guest
Rodan appears as an assist trophy
[Music]
Warriors final smash warrior man has
changed quite a bit after transformation
he no longer uses individual attacks to
get the job done
[Music]
Donkey Kong's final smash is all
rapid-fire punches like Donkey Kong
jungle bee
you'll notice that he and other fighters
have expressive new facial animations
[Music]
a little max final smash is now a Russia
flows from Giga Mac in fact all final
smash groups in the game get right to
the punch meshes new final smash calls
in Tala and poof of course Jeff still
shows up as an assist trophy
[Music]
likewise Lucas's final smash features
kumatora info
at first glance read the trainer seems
the same but her face has a new look I
wavered a bit on whether to change it
but it was a request from the wheat-rick
developers
[Music]
we've included all the hazards from both
versions of megaman stage from super
smash brothers for Wii U and Nintendo
3ds
and for his final smash say hello to
proto man and bass
[Music]
palutena's special tanks have been
streamlined this time around and her
down special is now both a counter and a
deflector rob has a new gauge on his
chassis showing how much fuel he has
left for hovering
[Music]
notice the epsilon symbols next to
Lucena in dark pits numbers each of
these fighters are based on another
fighter in the game we're treating these
fighters a little differently and have
decided to call them Negril fighters
allow me to introduce a brand new eco
fighter
Daisy joins a roster as peaches eco
fighter
she fights in a similar manner speech
but they have different characteristics
which we hope you'll enjoy have fun
playing as your favorite princesses
all-in-all if you add up the changes
were making there could be tens of
thousands I hope you're looking forward
to some serious magics and here's a new
fighter
[Music]
Pinklon is a completely new addition to
the roster
if you ink opponents they'll take more
damage from attacks
different weapons are available at smash
attacks or special attacks the
splattershot splat bombs
splat roller and the final smash killer
whale
you can actually run out of ink so it's
important to refill by pressing the B
button while shielding dinking boy also
debuts alongside inkling girl Inklings
are very fashionable all they'd have
their own outfits
and each has their own ink color for
matches that really bright by the way we
added in the squid sisters as an assist
trophy during their live concert the
camera zooms in for a close-up
that means it's easier to get knocked
off the screen
[Applause]
while we're on the topic of assist
trophies let me share some additional
information as you may know assist
trophies lend helpful support in battles
you can ko assist trophies by inflicting
damage and now you get points for it too
[Music]
however some assist trophies will remain
unbeatable maybe an unexpected guest
will photobomb your battle yep it's him
[Music]
there's a wide variety more than 50 of
them here in the game
[Music]
[Applause]
of course we're also adding even more
Pokemon and items we can't wait to show
you
[Music]
you
there are a variety of stages available
in this game as well including a massive
list of returning stages if you get a
group together to play it'll be a
challenge to hit them all the graphics
have been improved as well let's get a
look at some stages from various games
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all stages now have both battlefield and
Omega forms - these versions hover above
an abyss their sizes and terrain are all
the same so savor the simplicity music
and backgrounds from your favorite
series let's take a sneak peek at the
new and returning techniques you can
pull off during the battles
[Music]
the directional air dodge enhances
mobility
it can come in handy when recovering
from a ball however if you dodge too
much even on the ground you'll be wide
open to attack and your duration of
intangibility
gets shorter
[Music]
you can execute short hop attacks by
pressing the a button and jump at any
time
also you can smash attack by pressing
the a and B buttons just like the
previous game
a perfect shield occurs when you release
the shield button
until now we were able to pull it off
without any major risk but going forward
you'll need to time it carefully for
one-on-one battles the damage dealt will
now be greater than in battles with
higher numbers of players this should
help ensure that the action is well
paced in a timed battle the fighter and
the lead is sometimes flash with life
better do something or no victory pose
for you we've got something special for
your playing pleasure and Super Smash
Brothers ultimate
[Music]
Nintendo GameCube controllers can be
used in Super Smash Brothers ultimate
for many of you it just isn't the same
without them
not to mention all Super Smash Brothers
series amiibo figures are compatible
this time as well in fact all fighters
current amiibo figures will be supported
even if they're from a different series
tap a compatible amiibo figure to add in
a figure player or FP and level up your
heavy data from previous titles can be
transferred we hope you're as excited as
we are our staff will continue working
hard until the game releases we really
appreciate your support we've made
including every single fighter ever our
number one goal some kind of hoping you
aren't expecting too many challenges
however we do have one more announcement
both please take a look
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good morning everyone and welcome to
Nintendo treehouse live from the Los
Angeles Convention Center and III mean
the Somoza mas Los Angeles no III Kyoto
no Nintendo treehouse live machine
Yokoso like to say thank you to everyone
around the world for tuning in to our
Nintendo Direct as well as our fans in
Japan
zessica alumina Sangha Nintendo Direct
Amity that I J so she token in even know
capsule meeting tonight at all more
arigato gozaimasu
I am bill trainin I am here with Nate
build orphan eric smith from the
treehouse
look what Surrey house nobility oriental
a tornado beard or hunt or mean Eric
Smith sang nan desu ka Domo we have a
very special guest for you this morning
we just saw a new character announced
Nate why don't you tell us who we have
and what we're going to see much like it
even more cool I talk about any special
guests to got well done stated itthere
donate some yokai only guy touching us
yeah I know that was a probably lot of
smash to digest for those of you viewing
at home mister Sakurai on video explain
quite a bit to us but we are very
fortunate to have a live mr. Sakurai
here with us with his translator Raymond
LG Samsung Smart Remote
kumahachi Oh Yoshi much like a little
more queso Unga octet honing programs
data right here - I came on some
recently give us why this and my heart
just fall state they're sort of a topic
addicted to you coddle it I stay more su
bokuden any more ene own activities I'm
really speechless at the fact that we've
been working so hard and we're finally
able to announce this guy game
Nakamura Cara Cairo cannot be so I think
I'm just gonna go home now yeah
well I want to jump into some some more
specific details but before we start
this mr. sacker I have anything he wants
to say just in general about the games
developer mom what you don't corrigan a
little short guys ticket I come on the
skated um all right so legit so Imperial
- acurite's Ankara no mr. Jo Anika NIDA
Shekhar Kapoor our new detail on the in
toto fat estas - you coded s she needs
to know most are como se llama Sangha
kokumo de agua note on the Benjamin
cannot want a Sony Dicky Thomas
Indelicato muy mas so the biggest appear
of this game is really that everyone
every single fighter is back here and
you know may continue this match series
in the future but I don't know if we'll
ever be able to pull this off so I
really hope that you enjoy this
iteration of the game I certainly plan
to enjoy suited well so we mr. Sakurai
really delineating a lot of this Pacific
moose for returning fighters in the
video but we only got a taste of Ridley
at the very end so what I was hoping we
could do is maybe play through a little
bit with Ridley live on stage here so we
can talk a little bit more about his
moves and see what he looks like in
action
my mother'll don't fight that that you
know was I took out you know system HD
talking much like a little more who
knows Kentucky without a master not
there okay so I did to em prey they
literally know was a more so Christ a in
turducken I - okay so that's me
jaw chuck that sock they yeah he must be
all right yeah let's go ahead and give
you guys a tour where would you like to
fight
Doka Doka but as I said today that kid
on day so the shooting day so I'm just
gonna do an explanation so let's just go
to final destination and this final
destination is actually a special
version of final destination that is
going to be slightly different from the
version that's in the full game correct
so this human oh yeah shoot anger yeah
but you got this because you're saying
you know barge on this name soul
optimist that's correct
and that was a bit of a change right
there that we picked the state before
the character's name guarana Tori to
check out of corn on the scale no more
cheap on sighs show me a table Aloha
hi taj enact a stage name serenity to
autodefense misrata hi and let me get
into ridley now toreador you are a fool
yeah should I cut oh you all right oh
come on cinema Sangha I'm a totally
those cities we know some of the most
ridiculously as you may or may not know
Ridley is from the Metroid series and
his the arch-nemesis of Samus bikini for
Fito prophet taught emojis wasn't sure
what economy and comparatively he's and
she very very tight four meters tall
so no Takara photo motto monogamous cos
captain Odessa God pookie-kai guy Cara
no yoga Tommy needs editorial
desensitization much stuff and because
of that it was very hard to actually get
him into the game in a working
convention but there was a lot of outcry
from fans especially overseas so we
decided to put him in
ah say wa itsumo baka dawa didn't I
taking in Zangaro hoodies in terms of
his characteristic and in terms of smash
brothers he's very much on the cruel
side
Samara today Adventure mode of do you
know very much they somersault company
Quad City skater HD must recover and in
raw he made an appearance as a boss and
he will do moves like grabbing Santa's
and just dragging her across the wall
hey Jim in Casa de Paris and now he
drags other fighters along the for talk
to the jump oh study toca a portion of
the things you can do jumps while he's
grabbing on so opponents into all other
kinds of technical news to sort o new
tourists at sort of ah-ha-ha-ha
convinced kill anyone in this neutral
special is a fireball as you can see
both America
kosuna tomahawk origins and charging it
up you can throw multiple fireballs you
two against a katana G day a comet okay
no question on Akaka jump in on his name
and just like the original game his weak
point is actually when he's charging up
the fireball in his mouth nobody even
knew boku no Thomas little color
so just from that one hit he took about
20 26 percent of damage right now but
you take big damage at all so sucky much
good Scottish much sort of the way how
if kids are not in this God and his up
special is is what you just saw right
here
whoo-hoo you're awkward kind of
qualities and you can go on any for
directions you'd like
Nanami Madonna mr. Dubois is capitalist
Young's name and you can actually set it
to the equity down or forward or
diagonally down backward and the angles
a little bit different for each so the
co-star shots are talking about in this
get the more Korogocho proportion I was
at least eight and he also has a down
special as you just saw and this has a
very unique attribute at all body at all
tight areas in sumo kiss ticket outside
please take a close look at Mario's
damage percentage
[Music]
you cannot even see toes photocopy a so
Connie - creaks - the toe die damage or
terra-cotta with my soul tonight - photo
come on so we consulted you sit in this
me
so this move actually has a sweet spot
and when you hit it right at the sweet
spot takes huge massive damage but if
you don't and just attack and normally
it's very a minimal damage
what about on all your putti Union ties
them up took you to hold out that ya see
- - and I think a relatively speaking I
think it's easier to hit that sweet spot
when you're doing a four-player match
editorial sets of a while Julie's all
right and I think that wraps up Ridley's
blue set all right I'd like to stop just
getting beaten up here for a second so I
was kind of hoping that next maybe we
could actually play a match and see what
it looks like an action how do you guys
feel about that
macho means tightening mask a little
more circuit is not they donate Santo
Eric Tsang studied a licensed MRI much
okay all right sounds good you gotta
stop getting beaten up but de coco
Vanina and I can just get a job Perez
somos story doing this may squash Christ
so my general - your sniper with us all
right god samisen really and I'll do
some commentating while we're battling
Matsuzaka school by Delta is 3G select /
sake data you understand simply it's our
time
so first I'd like to start off with what
Nate mentioned earlier about having a
stage select before you select the
fighters stage in October I thought I
said I'd show through Nevada muskoxen
dejado we talked about the top four hits
you got you know me you know every
fighter and every stage has advantage
and disadvantage in combination so if
you look at kind of the extreme little
Mac is very useful on a flat surface so
for their stage you're sucking it up
conventional stuff Tokui available
market a goggle you only suit or a
certain go head over Moscow - and so add
- add a little bit of strategic we
decided to be able to select the stage
beforehand and that way in in a series
of matches the loser gets to take the
stage well among a squad you gotta work
early so far and I think you might have
seen the score display their intention
about it is quite huge open our footage
massed artillery not paramedics and then
for one-on-one battles we decided to put
a score display the score like that and
obviously you lose when you reach there
oh don't do this
good triumphs rocky god they cannot that
is never not God or mythos of the ocean
like this Nate has no mercy
oh here we go oh come on man it's just
that should be illegal in this car mono
mother hey Hot Tuna Valjean this year
hey da Vinci Chico catarrian science we
talk for economic choice of Commerce and
and of course this game is still in
development so the damage ratio where
the sweet spot is things like that may
change the future so before a movie to
the mall connoisseur say Master Wong one
dimension overtake us our table mode a
to the only place in the article Quixote
more damages you have forgotten optimist
and as I mentioned in the video earlier
there is this one-on-one damage where
you take on more damage and that's been
implemented here so close that I believe
autopen you're not doin it and as we
speak we're at its high right now even
though I'm at the pathology item today
this is a new item we see on screen here
so no no mo product cu-boulder's in this
kit at Ang's this new item is about
black hole yes Olynyk on a purchasing
common no one of this basically what has
a fine attracts all the fighters into
the center of that black hole a poem
assist authority assisted video gives to
the Cova became a satanic technical
canine oh they got some money playing a
heck of a stand and acknowledge this
it's usually only gets points in time
methods but as we're speaking we've got
a finals match then you can see samus's
ship crashing in the back who [ __ ] on
the summer snow juice I think should it
be you know immediate mercy on there no
oh no it's got the little construe so
much they often enjoy that yeah
animation and it looks like we've added
some new alright I thought I'd see
Pokemon we ma they must sail in Ottawa
I've got a deal all right miss me yeah
the stock right from the previous night
Oh get out ah goddamnit you got screen
with a company called sparing us so yeah
the damage which was low and that's why
we're able to get out of mas Galaga Oh
policy for bodies and this view item
let's just stick this up in the air real
quick
that was bad I start rcco kotsky much
there hey we were still poor
she called Chaucer they give us the fire
codes that also puts input on and we
actually added a new spec to the warp
star so holding up you can actually
delay when the ones are fall sorry and
you can adjust when either make it
quickly or slower I'm burning now you
might almost supercardioid ever stuck to
the wall
oh no my car came on that I'm always
curious you know Sam hate the curry but
I was wondering do overseas people get
that you know it's burning and spicy oh
yeah daisuki I don't know that you know
I just like to point out that I want
while we were talking subjected right I
don't need a NATO song usually much done
hit their famous what had really ever do
to you Thomas London so you consider
discovery to be good
so there we go to Sunday sir besides
tell your parents so mr. soccer I would
you how would you like to play one
you'll need a tiny muscle car
yeah a mascot yeah alright let's do it
let's do a four player match what do you
guys say sensor what the enticing
shamash all right so it's kinda chilly
and socrata in song well I think over on
this one
put-put you the snake so we're on
outside
hey doors off hi gobo whoo all right now
we got controllers we're gonna go we go
out we'll figure it out oh sweet pea it
looks like I'm you go with the link I'm
gonna go with Ganondorf perhaps I will
stick with Mario since we just Nate get
beat up as Mario Metal Mario to say what
a boring up dismantle a book Mario and
thank God
buddy what's key that's demostrate so he
didn't say you like Mario so we are on
great plateau to tower here from breadth
of the wild rest of the wire with no
hajimari no father's name hi Nick you
are hi do Kouga edge secular means you
got night book you are on or can people
are sort of it was nice
so link when keith has no damage she can
actually should have played and I
noticed that Nintendogs the type of dog
has changed I saw some over oxidative in
this game I can show quite a mess and I
don't know if you noticed but the in ten
dogs have been coming out since bra but
every time it's been it
different type of stock boy at or near
for Moda differente under skin at the
wall a little more than you toid food or
nothing's so it used to be a French
Bulldog in the last iteration but this
time it's a toy poodle you here we go oh
not me oh wait that's it I guess I cut
it off Oh curry so pulled a sucky gotten
it all the people saying
Oh No martini that was not good
I love seeing that tower collapse of a
new platform appears so they Tower
coordination money I thought I see
platform with that I don't wait it out
other way they just you know that's the
way this name
[Music]
I can I hope then we'll walk tight we're
good
give me more focus
something I don't know people are
noticing oh come on bill
Ganondorf now has sort of tax for all
his smash bros really hard my video demo
Mirotic a little more a ganondorf ooga a
punk I saw this I saw this this hold on
okay go get him o de Leon Lonnie Mercer
that's right and he also shows like look
it looked from ocarina of time and that
was unfortunate
IATA power
Oh tickle more to beware hard give up
serious your product his attack is very
strong
my god on door got stuck there that
restaurant Scott don't sit on it
I did Ganondorf just have a little
sparkle as I know that my imagination I
think it's because I haven't get
destroyed
yeah boss you go for it you going to
show you cannot also croc we got a good
match going here
why did I write into that vault door
opener
[Music]
Oh check out the boots
Oh
[Music]
Oh nothing's gonna stop that was run
over
yoga know that that is their
cost-cutting you got a good stick it
doesn't count
Matsumoto's in the
what are their what Maugham Oh buddy man
linking them what I must
I did get one point
on it you can you should not talk
talking mom Oh lost track my character
what I got on the roof we can endure
this
so you're doing
no you don't bill
[Applause]
[Music]
self-destruction are gonna help Thanks
oh that's a ringer wow that was that was
fun yeah that was yeah I almost want to
play again
yes Jamison day you know it's the type
of game where you kind of forget that
you're on life so you just want to play
and have fun so we've obviously talked
about Ridley we also in the direct we
talked about how this game is going to
use all of the previous amiibo masala
adrenals okay I'm the keymaster see
director no noggin you are a token kind
of a cacao amiibo resemble more scary
only in order to you unless you re
Marseille on there so that's me
so that does leave us with the question
of what would happen in the case of a if
he wanted a Wrigley amiibo there to go
to uh did you know reason one evil kick
you do not cut to you know that oh my
gosh you in there I think maybe we
should take this opportunity to show an
incredibly detailed Wrigley amiibo that
will be launching alongside the game say
Kaka destiny Nia no detail you got
ps-aguié
Tori Tori no amiibo so toe to toe Hudson
on desk a little more so stay toe snob
Rashidi is no
atarashii including no amiibo more
además and we also have a new inkling
amiibo for the Smash Brothers series
what does she believe Alito boots the
Hodgman in Australia I think it's the
first time I've seen like a 3d
realization of
yes good parasite record about me in
this I mean obviously I've seen it
during production and development but
could I have a show see this car ah and
can I share something a little maybe a
little nerdy I mean what the hodge mitad
Ivana is a nice car so for the binary
including you know
unable to achieve sorry PO yes or no
mushi vomit on cool or metal song
kikuchiyo cheon isn't it so um there is
already an inkling amiibo and now that
we have a smash anything amiibo and I
wanted to kind of point out one
difference between those two and it's
that the little triangle ticker on the
ink tank behind the inkling the location
of that triangle ticker is a different
sort of our spot a super more ek-
looking heavy in Kenora wash dmoz kurwa
it over there he says I'm not in the
kickboxing special my goodness me Dakara
Chioggia cockpit sauna penis and that
mark denotes how much ink you use up
when you use the splat bomb but the
amount of ink you use insta to NAND
smash is different it's in Smash it's a
special move so you can use a lot more
splat bomb so the speck is a little
different details man DJ details and
although we we don't have a figure to
show today we did also introduce Daisy
as an echo fighter in the game and we
can confirm that there will also be
Daisy amiibo in the Smash Brothers
series releasing as well
the mark Yoda tribute to a missile early
90s carried on more video on a canoe a
toad a g PG meno - Rita touch - okay Sal
can escape Adamo some opera CDs no
amiibo no Daisy more
it's your new ish mass high second s not
a matter
I wasn't doing my talker more you sing
Maury said yeah let's do it
I think we're over there well put a
little comment cutting out the wall
thank you thank you nub that one's a
little bit shorter like a bill there we
go
ja including you know how a sumo does
she couldn't be almost a sneaky Moscow
well we did talk about inkling so shall
we go to the Inklings
Saudis Nick let's do right now
[Music]
Nautica including the positive over use
a short name maybe someone can I'm don't
talk much okay
so the house - on the skid or always
open after photo module area I go in
talk cuts given two different versions
have the ratings ingredient done so
popular cut I could be to you and I
guess I will go as elder I love this
elder redesign I think our work is
excellent
so as news ever done or Cara more to do
more Carson air design goes but I see
this you cannot parish hall yeah looks
good right mama dada see disrepair
Wanda GCD Sukarno Semper Tyrannis name
concave up our entire a reunion our
table a episodes already skinned up a
poor way around the nostril
so in the past we've made it so all the
other related characters are often the
same series but this time we've spread
it out so I think that what I really
like
oh [ __ ] oh god oh no their item or the
keys
so this stage had a lot of pills so it's
actually kind of difficult to use items
properly well it's all so much for
translation Oh smash support oh I don't
need some one of us must fall within
system or whatever thought Jews you know
Capuchin Otto the calcaneal so there's
an actual smash part and then there's a
fake Smash Ball in there and you can
discern which one is fake by the market
on the ball
Ottawa for one of us that is a real one
yes
yeah I start you here we go Edith eat
that's nice that's not gonna be good
very good
that was a worthy suitor honest and that
was do now on just now Oh too slow
including unit bento Sarita character
wha succeed avez you know tomorrow yoga
sahaja Yoga for to not move it you're
chief Smith and as I mentioned when
characters are painted by the Inklings
deep they actually end up taking more
damage so you got a beware
Oh
[Music]
stop Oh care make me all you want
what can I oops oh yeah did naked
I just saw them come on
send your brows back three way something
that oh yes I I did not have a good
match boy at the government or somebody
or Nothing this and two wins for mr.
soccer right Scots goes he's played
before he show this and their injustice
everybody put audio go thank you for a
wonderful game so humble yeah well I
think you know before we go I if there's
anything you know last thoughts in mr.
sacker I wants to leave the fans with I
really appreciate you spending time with
us today so any any final thoughts for
everybody watching duh what am i nice
sakurai-san Carnot cycles taco to Anika
naughty monster show crime so today I
know
EEMA character determined a scale
democra ECD by John Scott Leamas Sony CD
by John Day a new home commit yoga
korekara Co de Luca Toni Naruto Mama's
mother
hi Hatsune see but also say to Jason da
da da da no character was harder to me
Massimo gay
sky guard Mustafa the he thought the
italic ad bottle - so state cuts by bill
I watch it ok - Papa - so the characters
you just saw it's a part of the ìiî
version and in this version will may
become playable and in certain time and
I hope that and obviously we're in the
middle of development and balancing is
still being made so it may be some
changes but I hope that if you have the
opportunity to please check it out we
can't include all characters but I think
you'll get a good feel for it and I
really hope you look forward to the
release of the game
that's great well it's been really fun
losing to you over and over again thank
you so much for spend time with us today
it's been it's been really fun
well the lucky panache is I stuck a
little more hunting come on shut up
chicken go more I didn't say much that
nobody told us thank you very much and
thank you for turning in the tree house
5 we have more coming up there will be
more smash brothers with lots of detail
on additional characters over the course
of e3 but coming up next after a short
break we're going to have the world's
first hands-on play with Pokemon let's
go Pikachu and Pokemon let's go EB along
with a very special guest the tree house
I walk on rocky mascara Domo touch this
Murano Sakai mode ando ando bonito con
show guy sticky mascara
Domo to Eva for Pokemon let's go catch a
Pokemon let's go EB no sekai ha to Jitsu
and prey showcase item ot mustachio
break you got a mascara da Mosta motto
tokubetsu na guess - mata for dan-shim a
snow day Kisuke euros cool nagashi mas
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good morning everyone and welcome back
to Nintendo treehouse live at the LA
Convention Center and E at e3 - ah I was
I must see house of Ivo Casa Mata Los
Angeles no III know kadokura - Sheamus
today we are very very fortunate we have
a very special guest mr. Matsuda from
gamefreak and he has even brought
Pikachu with him he's Albertson
augustama polar satellite game freakin
omatsu DiSanto be cut to maturity much I
gotcha gotcha and translating for him we
have David along with Evy this ouya
karate because on unionize they'ii be
multi-ethnic tomas I am bill trainin and
this is Teresa were from Nintendo okay
but everyone in ten don't know Toby
written in toe toe terraces Angus you're
also a CMOS yes Connie nice math before
we begin playing Masuda song I wanted to
hear from you and I think everybody
would like to hear from you first what
are we're your goals in designing and
developing Pokemon let's go pikachu and
pokemon let's go eb - and put it - uh hi
the cool guy no Pikachu let's go take a
Pokemon let's go - got you okay Mon
let's go even know how Hudson he
attacked their Ichi pantastico katakana
San Antonio second open estonia sunday
mauritania Demonte in mumbai kolkata
gotten on game okeyday akatsuki my
staccato okay sweetie today no giving
today Mina / - Thomas in Davos in atomic
death
hey Mediano mommy nervous / - okay -
monster pass you're my master so as we
always do with the Pokemon games you
really want everyone around the world to
really enjoy these games up until now
we've developed them on handheld systems
but this time around of course it's a
Nintendo switch which we envision people
are going to be playing in their living
room so we had another take on Pokemon
in general you know what would that look
like and what would a Pokemon for
everyone be
Master comedienne own demented Japan on
Kodomo tachi I'm a Pokemon go today my
prediction I totally know des animaux
Pokemon go user more empanadas Teresa
mode a mom in a bun Tony Tan on
sabbatical go use a pedometer seymour mo
mother no phenomena more tan on similar
forget the monster sorry up on kind no
debts ago that relates very much I also
had in mind a lot of the younger kids
maybe don't have their own smartphones
to play pokemon and go there's so many
people have to claim pokemon go but some
of the younger kids maybe didn't get a
chance to do that so I had them in mind
as well as all of our existing fans
really wanting this to be truly a
Pokemon for everyone
great well why don't we take a look at
the game and show the world Pokemon
let's go Pikachu there was also could
ask a little more I thought it's um
pretty high-tech no no second Amina's on
the Pokemon let's go pika okay she much
more so this net this is Viridian Forest
that we have just entered Eamon Gilmore
adición a soulless Coco no - ah no no
casino Tokyo no Mario oh whatever
special car Condon or 3d day with cushy
Tokyo know what in there myself
this may be a familiar location for a
lot of our fans that played the the
older games but they're kind of come
back to life in 3d here yes it looks
wonderful you can see Pokemon out in the
field you can see the shafts of light
the companies Aparecida snail or Atari
toka toka somewhere on the Pokemon meter
HD my soul
you know HT must be somewhat you see all
the pokemon popping up from the grass
and I see here that we've entered now a
wild Pokemon battle and we've changed
the mechanics for how we're capturing
wild Pokemon can you tell us about that
a bit
hey mama if I say no Pokemon no it's
comedy gamma and disunity well that's
all covered in our side we took two
semesters I mean my mother you know part
of the day I know what state has a
Pokemon right here still hold on I'll
get it
and a moral to votó para macho can take
any poor Xury como parte de menthe a
negated oh my board will Nuggets come
hydrophobic finish things up until now
on the Pokemon games the wild Pokemon
you encounter you go into a battle and
then you kind of reduce their hit points
weaken them a bit and then you're able
to catch them but with these games being
on Nintendo switch and of course in the
living room you've figured people will
be playing along with their friends and
family we want to do a new take on this
kind of Pokemon catching experience with
these intuitive controls we're just kind
of flicking the Nintendo switch
controller and throwing out pokeballs no
Pokemon go they can take any course naka
de por una gaita Tamil Kannada Marathi
and also BS - okay Doretta - namaste
okay sorry oh sorry Nico 16 oh joy Conda
and taken fruit Dave Savini taking a
tannish inkatha's on my side and that's
taking a hint from Pokemon go which I
worked on and came up with the catching
mechanic and that which used the
smartphone controls people found that
really intuitive I think they're widely
accepted and kind of gained a lot of
popularity so I wanted to do a take on
that using the joy con - a similar style
where it's much more interactive kind of
a
experiential thing yes and in fact you
mentioned the joy con and Teresa is
playing with a single toy con you're
able to play the entire game with just
one joy con the image icon will show
them our psychology - a joy concoct a
they're also very own at the mercy of
this ridiculous
Caetano Kiki de navarra´ catotti the
game possibilities Chicago Kangin on
Tomo
the lame oh yeah I think having one joy
cutting it will play the entire game
with it as a very comfortable and kind
of a pleasurable experience you can
maybe be eatin popcorn with your other
hand for example and I also say that
when you capture wild Pokemon you earn
experience points and those get shared
among the entire Pokemon in your party
the Amano Rita yoni y'all see the
Pokemon wall coming at all hi Kenji got
Amani Monsieur name no party no Pokemon
noir yattaman
core idea no data no Pokemon tateyama
don't don't go to penalty stop yo Tony
heaven o matic America today
a Maori hey Thomas America hey yo D
Pokemon that you got so that stop you
know basic expectable the gaining
experience points of course levels up
the Pokemon in your party gives and get
some stronger so that's how you kind of
your strengths in your pokemons main
mechanic of that we really wanted to
focus on that catching experience so
made sure that you can also strengthen
your Pokemon just by catching pokémon
and I think you also can do different
throwing motions to try to catch pokemon
as well come on lucky cut them all
either Widow cuckoo famous your name no
Nana many worked on the study
Yoko Cara for Yoko knee side of the
roster the toe and the openings on day
Torito so know what Iman Oh sighs oh no
poor Allah how many Pokemon wait tonight
schedule Coco Pokemon we'll go get us
something
Sonia was it a don't a negated a
technique creaminess a no technique oh
no no not even if you cut them or you
don't know technically I was it yeah you
can do a variety of different throwing
techniques like you can put a little bit
of an angle on it to throw diagonally or
throw to the side or even do an
underhand lob type of thing and right
now in these early parts of the game
you'll see that the pokémon aren't
moving around very much but later on
they're gonna be moving around so you're
gonna need to try a lot of different
techniques no it looks like a female
Pikachu just a bottle this hook you up
don't wanna [ __ ] you know anything about
my skill I think Rhydian forest you know
Pikachu is well-known for this location
so Teresa you want to try a side throw
or something like that a little bit more
of a challenge the cat has switched to
an ultra wall no scientists roto totem
is teeny mosquito Monica - coyote
puts come on Nick we know they're wrong
I mean like a little bit of a diagonal
throw there
[Music]
nice job thank you
now I think we've been seeing as as
Teresa is walking around that her
character has Pikachu on the shoulder
but there's also Charmander following
her around can you talk a little bit
about the differences between the two
partner Pokemon am I on my own ESS on
our original do I need Pikachu the
happening update there we should only
talk okay got it in the scheduler hi
that's my Pokemon logic I need to eat
this assume a state like Moscow cottony
she's gonna cut onion or Terranova
eyeball or capture this let's go that
you do I got yoga yeah able to stick
cotton in obtained tea and its really
pretty well at Amano Vinnie she cannot
Amano a need a Big O notation evoking on
come on Sheamus they don't need to know
I know so they are you know Pokemon this
stage okay Wow
Savino which is a Pokemon that's
ridiculous Tina Pokemon well no Dakota
next I'm Thomas and these games you have
your partner Pokemon which is of course
Pikachu and let's go Pikachu and Eevee
and let's go EB if you could she rides
your shoulder Eevee rides on your head
and besides that you can have any of the
other pokémon you catch in the game
follow behind you in addition to your
partner Pokemon
some of them you can even ride on them
if they're big enough so there's a
definitely a lot of variation to the
Pokemon that will follow you and now I
say we've entered into our first trainer
battle and what we see with the trainer
battles is that this is a more
traditional battle screen type of an
experience Limon origin McDonald 3
Nevada not a scary don't want ya meaty
meat at all
Naruto a geochemist Pokemon Lhasa to the
muddy much they're supporting Hamas much
Toto Toto Toronado sediba to Rosarito
llamo Samira mata Mata it is see attano
Susan high center known as Jana today
stupid Tora prison Pokemon mom take a
so-called
you know ma it's open all on the point
to all siding that competitive battling
aspect you know players between players
or pokemon trainers as pokémon trainers
it's really part of what makes Pokemon
Pokemon so we definitely preserve the
battles as as they were in previous
games you can also of course tricked you
to battle against the trainers in the
game but also do linked battles so
playing against other real players
battling each other with your Pokemon no
joke on their heads chimera
tigress Obito Toronado CD echo
authoritative
Tatsuno so vacatio sorezore a huacatay
watch because our Athena's so in these
games you'll see that there's quite a
difference between the catching gameplay
which you're using the joique on to
flick out and throw actually throw a
pokeballs and then the battle gameplay
which is more traditional selecting
commands to fight issue moves and battle
T against the other trainer
yeah I think we also we see the Pokemon
in the grass we've even seen with some
of the Pokemon that there are graphic
indicators some kind of aura around the
Pokemon is that correct
all right we're on a pokémon's apnea
Teresa mascara dome on the model vehicle
no graphics took me really Optimus name
so it's Knox annulus eterno Alki or
evaporate and now a war about their
hateful mama no nami T Montgomery also
to specification on this day the more oh
keep okay Morris Tomatoes okay we did
this to really make it so you players
would want to catch that even a bunch of
the same species of pokémon so there's a
little bit of differentiators there like
red aura to indicate bigger Pokemon of
that species or blue or to indicate that
they're much smaller than normal
I'm quite damaged talking ah you shoulda
known that even just having Charmander
follow you around like this kind of fun
as a pokemon trainer that's right and I
notice here that Pikachu's wagging its
tail the within me Toto Pikachu
Tomas na hi I know eyeball that no
tokubetsu na Mario Kanishka toe Ondo go
Garrett oh hey Oh se la vista crema the
special ability or power you might say
of your partner pokemon it'll wag its
tail when there's an item nearby and
letting you know that there's something
to pick up so it looks like with the
redesign of the Kanto region that as
you've turned it into 3d you've really
taken that into account to kind of hide
items throughout the world the
conquering will come to achieve all that
3d it's beautiful thing out there sorry
oats birthday edo edo kuhu more steam a
sushi a night and go Kokomo
sodas no no a Perico my mama de su d de
want a todo el mundo para dead Tina
Varma moto moto de hermano post SVD Nina
Tahoe today Martin Assad
papa vamos a Pinot ma medio clicking
news video you're immediately in
material ports customers that's right I
think the original games that we face
these off of you know better on the
Gameboy 2d pixel art monochrome
monochrome but you know - black and
white pretty much and these times I
think we've recreated them in 3d so
there's gonna be a lot of fun things the
players are gonna be able to discover
and I think we've really made them just
kind of look really more appealing than
before
yeah I really love the graphic look of
the game because it does feel like it's
gotten a lot closer to what people may
remember from the anime which I think
will be great for longtime fans this or
the snail or graphics uno go gang ard
anime meet Iona ensure that su it is
named sorry one like I didn't know
Pokemon me popular that's cash engine is
for this nano no moto moto Pikachu
foundation is tablet in landscape or no
chinko camo cottony schedule of the
phenomenon suppose to walk instead of
eternal Angela Yahtzee
no Pokemon that stirred own oil in there
take that deal more mano
so opponent animate oppa hey my mother
know so it's a city's penis out Kanika
get a good advice from Okinawa yoga
dirty took a car there touka-sama Nagato
Mazepa Rihanna Angeles yeah there's
definitely that aspect of course Pikachu
being on your shoulder maybe even makes
you feel a little bit like ash from the
animated series in these games it's not
just the animated series that we've
really tried to take an amalgamation of
these different expressions that you see
in the card game for example the
definite for the animated series and the
animated movies and really just trying
to express that through how the Pokemon
move about and how you encounter them in
the game
so I say we're in another wild Pokemon
battle with Teresa doing an under throw
there we all say in the Pokemon come I
recommend they're under so it is a buy
signal myself yeah you did a good job
there yeah I know
sighs any boat I'll post a joke on no I
don't know boy lady said toasty Milano
day I think about our stay
shouldn't this be the more cocoa no Naga
joke on the decepticon you become a
technique imatra know them as
tummy storsie nonetheless it's a bit
technical about how you can actually
change your throwing technique but when
you press the kind of get in position
button it resets the gyro position so
from there is where it thinks it's kind
of the normal position and that doing
that depending on where you're holding
the controller at the time can allow you
to do a variety of different things but
of course when you're you can also play
the game handheld mode if you decide to
take it off the TV and in that case
you're able to play with button controls
correct there are no children television
Octomom are switch thusly they're a
hundred or hi they also better put the
world piggy must receive the service
name want a comp Ajo de contas erotic
moment ago past a chaos of Iona es
commenced for Burma but instead Amato
pop with ammonia was it a play about our
state bottle capacity in handheld mode
it's a slightly different style of
gameplay we're actually taking the
entire system itself and using the gyro
inside of that you press the button to
get in position and then there's a
target that appears you've got a aligned
that with the Pokemon and then get your
timing right press the button to throw a
Pokeball
[Music]
so but I think we also have another mode
that perhaps we wanted to talk about
that also takes advantage of the switch
and a second joy con-dem are no more
support Inacio stuck at the Morton or
Moto e muscle name hi mojito to naj
Alikhan what's called option thusly hi
I know Peter doctor knee and me standing
this me yeah
goody no hey Sanchez correct mark
credited in the SCADA more so you gotta
say the doc you are a soupy Java the
pseudocode a more study no support
amakura noir origin
in the bottom right of the screen are
actually in the right of the screen in
the battle mode you may have just seen
that but it indicates that you can have
a second player join your game simply by
shaking the second controller and second
joique on my secondary and then there's
the port support character
so I'm now playing together with Theresa
Lepore Booga
today's a sample study day Sunday Mass
hi piranha kikyo how was it they're
bored or not get it off put it
challenger this on give it a try try
getting into full synchronisation here
at each other throwing these pokeballs
challenge accepted okay I challenge you
get put in one side one two three oh I
see fidelity that was a good throw two
three
when you got in looks away this man two
in a row row on top nice
[Music]
did it
nice seein it nice if you want to make a
comment though that in the TV show there
are a lot of Pokemon trainers that were
able to catch pokemon without battling
them so you kind of get that sense here
with the wild Pokemon encounters it's
really
my soul is knocking oh they are anime no
Hana she was a massage no more mm you
were the popular certainly we are say in
the [ __ ] moon
Kamiya three know that you are in my
Sunday hi Zoe Chico Guerra de Mesilla no
Bordeaux iconic oh ha no skirt Nagato
Katya Noah are some images in instance
yeah how you throw out that pokeball
that's really the entire experience if
you know catching pokémon in this game
so we definitely put a lot of care into
that yeah it's actually why don't we do
a trainer battle okay try to dodge all
of these Pokemon they're swimming today
oh c'mon it took three na by three up in
you take the one that's good to go more
high though Pokemon kick boy
it's alright so pull out a lot of okay
m'lady to fuss around there yeah and
then pretty important in particular
there's just a ton of Pokemon kind of
walking around the grass you see
so in a trainer battle both players get
to battle as well and that can be a big
help for somebody who's more of a novice
player the Train about the radula no
value of study demo the battle ax did
you not see me put a sufficiently
whatever keiko alingas unit salt no
pepper d being good a possessive the
game datacom its get a police arrest or
so support ostomy over on the moped
ishani thomas marry oniy and compare
stemis foods can be a lot of fun players
are in their living room playing on
their TVs and someone maybe comes in you
can just quickly join in the game and
enjoy the experience together
[Music]
okay no longer kimono Tomas I don't know
a committee today no longer cool really
classic finish the televi day keep them
all journey and of course to the town
awesome video and Stella we really took
the original music from the red and blue
games and kind of that really that
classic take but made them in really
high fidelity this time around so you
can even really enjoy listening it up to
your on your big-screen TV for example
yeah well I have always been a fan with
service on of your work on the music in
the Pokemon series so I'm very excited
to be able to experience that in my
living room like I either most of us
remember the Pokemon series they picked
out - ah word in / Sugoi ha ha no Jimmy
this same for me like the last time I
played a Pokemon game and I'm
embarrassed but it was back in the
Gameboy era so this is super nostalgic
for me I'm really excited to play it
completely so it's nestled somewhere
told you know for came on Sunday
oh no como yo knee for my I'm not old
you know also be about 30 videos of a
latino boy not scratch saga very much
parents then someone say toast you know
fun no katachi Moses see I know my
protein code I take volcano and
dosimeter a captain evocative on day and
has imitate Pokemon place totally SHINee
[Music]
not this time call kite I chose an
isolation eternal submitted they even
take you to three not anymore I think
one fun aspect of that is for players
who may be enjoyed the original a
generation of Pokemon games they'll
generally know how the adventure goes in
these games and be able to kind of give
maybe advice or help maybe guide some of
the younger players may be enjoying
these for the first time and it looks
like Teresa has disciple DiMaggio
modernist Yoko
they kinda naughty western a New York
that is a ton of big onyx there that's
for sure yeah it's really cool that this
game really does show Pokemon in their
true scale format so it's really
interesting to see this tiny or smaller
Pokemon versus the ever majestic on it
so it's nichole kinda soft or Pokemon
hold on keyboard I watched a personally
I try Pokemon Thor and the Chi Chi GI
all missile with universe so it was
really high I know
the Kaito no detector not Monsieur neck
I think what the Pokemon or that big you
really just kinda as a player want to
ride them yeah nikka connemara in data
on coral Atari toka an okay quano idea
toka motion design a machine de tiramisu
but you're gonna see that our animators
got really creative with some of the
Pokemon for example like electrode
instead of walking it's gonna be rolling
behind you like a ball
so it looks like we've gotten out of
Viridian Forest then we have now come to
Pewter City Lima autocue on Memorial Day
I wanna be cheating team harshly on it
so who who's this character that we're
seeing email character Don additional
time Coriana libelous name
[Music]
preyas cosas como desu kedo not achieve
an autogenous alito a total Chicago
character todos nós temos so this is
actually the rival in these games and
you'll see that it's different than the
rival that appeared in pokemon yellow
version which were these games are based
off them there's a lot of other
differences the characters as well
no but I bought a scarecrow since it
today hey Toki Nika whatta residence
kiddo ma
so no code Aquatica autonomous immune
system what about tonight you'll see
even though it we're technically calling
it your rival it's actually quite kind
to you of course he has other
personality traits like he gets scared
very easily I think you're gonna have
fun so you know in which situations he
gets scared at question or character
Nico henkka Omata Rossi character Joseph
a to Coto de a no at Arecibo event old
school today they put the most famous so
we've added there's some new events to
the games compared to the the originals
and also changed up the characters a bit
to make me kind of feel fresh that's
great well Teresa since we just went
through Viridian Forest and had a few
battles maybe we should go to the
pokémon center in heal or Pokemon Kumari
they drove approach Thank You Marcel hi
ok Monsanto Caillou cassava in July you
wanna see me no come on Santa
it's a pretty familiar location for fans
I think I like how Pikachu jumps off
your shoulder but we got to pop I got a
countdown in old lady you know how I did
asleep right happy mouth you know what
Italians the toad toad a certain and
Shogun state Alito
you may have seen in the Pokemon Center
we made sure to keep the original pixel
are not the original but the pixel art
for the Pokemon appearing on the screen
there now by the city teeny nothing more
not built to it there by name this year
I gave her gorilla loves the pixel art
even if we go to 3d we still want to
keep them in the game
that's right mother what they're no
Marty no not anymore Pokemon toy Sonny
Cory to stoke up in a snare you see lots
of residents of the town work walking
around living with their pokémon and the
town looks great something matcha guy I
know sukui Vicky got a this nation hi
devanam Amano side up a design of
embassy case you know all the buildings
been redesigned by all of our graphic
designers you were mentioning the
townspeople with their pokémon the solo
Morabito Cucamonga magiccatjenny
masquerade over hi this is a correct
yeah man that's a slowpoke as you can
see
in my mother and my summer schedule
based on the schedule a Pinto moto moto
an optimist so these kind of little
events with peppered throughout the game
that weren't in the original Pia pokemon
yellow version not opening on ojos de
todo de Janiero community no hominem in
odessa katsu sera congi to Nevada City
mohini Thomas I made it on my mouth part
of this was to really increase that
feeling of humans and pokémon living
together in the same world also very
interesting that the the world has
encouraged for the player to interact
with the world because you never know
what's going to happen it's really
my soul is near taco Konkan second Tony
pray you don't know moto interaction was
they do you think out there but you know
I promise me this name so this man
Superman ya don't ya don't I see pretty
slowpoke like things well perhaps we
should take her the advice of our rival
and head toward the gym yeah sure that's
great all right but advice would be
there Jim no only because each muscle -
hi sir
perpend are not Jimenez now who's the
germ obviously
[Music]
both the gyms have really changed in
design Jim not design work on recovery
mercenaire hi motorboating Avesta nan
desu kedo a known antidote na yo D Co Co
navasana Jimmy Carter kini Nina pour
concrete engineer papa
yes Cusco kurama's a famous from Okinawa
No
jiminy opera mode is another no hay
market Tsubasa go remove more
advertisements we make yeah we're making
these games on switch you know bringing
the the region to the the switch games
we took the original gyms as a base but
then thought what we could add on to it
kind of enriched the visuals and
everything we felt that made for this
gym you'd probably be some spectator
seats but depending on which gym you go
to a may even be completely different
from the pokemon yellow version for Iman
means a type of cook subtype with oats
come optimist cottage cut it on this
table so we guy was asking you if you
had a water or grass type Pokemon
[Music]
and so we're getting close to Brock who
appears in this game no pockets you got
to be must go to the wall man you up oh
yeah Bob I guess you feel there's rock
types you know it's all about Brock
right yes and we do see that we have
some some very fun lines from the past
game as well buckle no soft spot in the
city who wore all right on there
nope I doubt a knight is naked eyes you
know that's a to fill no stuff that's
you some of those lines really just
can't change
30 iconic I'd be sad if they weren't
there
so this Yaya no mikata younger Karishma
seoeon that's right given 30 watts good
paper buddy in court case and I dropped
in on life I had a puzzle day and not
just for the fans of its creators
ourselves you know we're making the
games like yeah we can't get rid of this
we gotta keep it as it was
so it's oh nice
all right you go get enough pressure
[Music]
yeah it's nice to be be able to battle
together there's a really cool thing too
as well not just with the trainer
battles but also the Pokemon encounters
you can feel everything every
interaction through the droidcon
it's really satisfying and really
so there's nae Ariana mud prenup after
the packaging up there Donna interaction
the Moya buddy pour TOI cone machine
today
hi Pike on the Chema's this week emoji
in this time I know we're a minute oh
[ __ ] oh look at that oh come on listen
only I know come on Jo no pie you know
no Sabattus it over optimum time for
Edith Emma and we really thought that
the HD rumble in the joy cons is a
really cool technology work put a lot of
care into making it feel good like when
when there's maybe you get attacked it
rumbles a little bit and it feels like
you know you're getting hit almost well
we'll put the switch in the Samuel is
every week I see my something hi really
using all of the features have been to
the switch
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I mean that's all unless you mean no
rock that everyone is familiar with I
think
[Music]
I think at this point we kind of want to
move topics switch gears and talk about
something else
that's right they were known to and play
well
Kyoto Tokyo ko stay higher capital topic
can you she must get it up high so we've
been playing with the joy Khan but of
course the game is also compatible with
a special new controller the pokeball
Plus remember there are no joy : there's
only much like a little more doji suou
momoko kibitz my controller
hey you're still my co knife the move
starboard across this name high and the
pokeball plus it acts as a joy con it
has all the functionality it's got a
control stick that you can press down
and even a button on the top the mod
company on oh joy call someone oh no key
no more high tea master Shi it's also a
stick tomorrow Momo karate master Shi
Tong
Adiemus Yamato talk business in Don
Octavio de cinta Okuda CEO it you
actually see that the rumble in the
pokeball was even stronger than a
typical joy concert it's a kind of a
special experience Jake on most of us or
no - Nico nani mo - i'm on starboard day
such a machine i don't want to move 2
o'clock western art opened a and
misogyny
its landing a nanny literally cannot go
knocking we needed to attain ultimate on
the skid oh my rock song right there and
on new session editor now they're only
say take up a unique aroma they call
Mira cheeky utility vehicle Mary Watson
de cocora zento I mean de niro condom
alright are not on optimus we're making
the pokeball plus we knew we were gonna
you know it was gonna come out but we
felt that if it was empty when you
bought it
you feel kind of lonely so we were
thinking of Pokemon to put inside of the
pokeball plus and players first get it
and deciding which Pokemon to put in
there we came up we just came down to
Mew you know the mythical Pokemon Muir
that'd be the most appropriate so when
players go to the store and they're on
their way back home with it they'll be
able to kind of hear you cry from inside
of the ball and the
experience that's right so then you can
transfer that mu into your game and you
can also put other Pokemon into the
pokeball and take them with you when you
go out on the walk and and then based on
your movement and your activity you can
then get presents in the game when you
bring the pokemon back then I'll shut
play Oni coming like any Pokemon the how
to cook already there
I'm Amir I toss off Tony pencils to the
Pokemon taking master Shi hi this dr.
farno vets know Pokemon more Pokemon
demo company canceled so the photo
editor hi somepony DJ totemo doki
obviously a normal ticket of my
Metallica President Obama is your
narrative re mask a domino eyeball coma
I will hide it on once kiddo
it's always the hi now cook on may be
here your partner crime here after I was
taking it up close to my mic so everyone
can hear Mike no chikaku knee with it
but what I really like about the
pokeball plus controller is the weight
the size and actually it just it feels
so good come on over : americana hollow
sized o'connell almost a dog hello Sean
no consequence in and so this children
yeah the field talk about was really
nice
nakooma led I don't know I don't know
them there are no Pokemon naruto hypu
toka a snake oh come on [ __ ] on
yahwah set hCAP 30 more MV must endure
the LED light that you can see at where
the the joystick is actually lights up
in a really wide variety of colors and
it kind of corresponds with the type of
the pokemon that inside of it
and then of course you can also connect
it to your cell phone and use it as a
Pokemon go plus and play pokemon go and
interact with focus tops and catch
pokemon just using this without taking
your phone out as well the kie more
stuff to push it moose and accept your
stay
the Pokemon go Prestwich that sky Rotom
oh hi I'm a Pokemon goat oh no thanks to
the top oh no come on go crust
your monster border put us so yeah it's
a pokeball plus B when you connect with
Pokemon go it works as a Pokemon go plus
that's right so lots of lots and lots of
functionality company you don't let sky
got that up if I promise to made it the
way my right
so beyond just sharing your adventure
with another player to play Cola you're
also able to battle and trade with other
players
maybe mr. Masseria has more information
on that feature
hey massacre of prey on me Satan is
carried on wall sorry guy need to design
a neon or pray for a toccata time oh no
Kokomo Vicki Marchionne a panel to sing
polka and it's written it's all based on
a bit
hey for your home ec stood soo awesome
edge tight on my mark so actually
brought a video to show us some of the
link trade and battle aspects great
let's take a look at the video video
meeting tomorrow
[Music]
hi forest fire estimado character sinto
internet solution Theodosius master a
single battery battery
Thomasson photo ridiculous as you can
see you can use that a local wireless or
connect over the internet to play do
link trades or do single battle and
double battle battles against friends
and other players team a pokemon added a
mosquito hey Susan Akashi wanna poke my
phone way down there some of Chimaera
setting up a salado cannot imagine
Joseph Adrianna Hopkins and you saw on
screen there's that link code once that
is pretty much a matchmaking password
you choose a combination of Pokemon and
are matched up with other players to
chose the same combination now they're
at home on that stole a statue even if
she didn't commit to this thing hey
console photo so you tell your friend
okay Pik Pikachu bulbs or and Eevee
and then we'll be able to connect and
trade together or battle together
okay put them away tom dick and pokemon
not here will it go into the trading
sequence
maybe I don't want see you later Baltics
my mom look I seen on the cable AGID I
know he made your [ __ ] that okay but
that's Taylor you can see that animation
is kind of reminiscent of the maybe the
link cable that you had to use to trade
pokémon back then we just kind of
digitized that into a cool trading
sequence
how about okay with it Connors got this
better memories of trading with that
link cable great but of course not only
can you trade pokémon with other players
but you can also connect with Pokemon go
and you can send Pokemon from Pokemon go
into Pokemon let's go Pikachu and let's
go Evie correct they put it on local
operator Pokemon go Pokemon scotoma
anymore okay Mungo ye such as oh fish
there and I know Pokemon go Pokemon oh
oh let's go Pikachu let's go he be me
hands into the photo vertically Marciano
could rocoto a ticket on optimist I know
go back to you mashallah re muscled it
puts it on more meaty meat i to my mass
there is actually a location that
facilitates that called go park and
hopefully we can show off a little bit
of what that is
quano moon casino safari zone hopscotch
Ogasawara johnston some pokemon yellow
version there was the safari zone but go
park actually isn't that same location
replaces it cocoa there hey come on not
go park on oh and cotoletta too much and
from there at the reception you can
choose which go park to go into nicola
pisano
aurora knows about committee can't
achieve on the pokemon god and it's
evacuated to a weenie no particular
photo attic you can bring from pokemon
go any of the Kanto region Pokemon
including there'll all and variants and
transfer them to the game it'll appear
in go park here this looks like a fun
place for the Pokemon Pokemon little - a
little more kimochi Vita is no no you
don't know what they call those muscle
there I don't not disconnect for any
Pokemon either
matadv desert Asano is all but too
stupid I get the Matano see the window
yeah and you'll see I'm just running
around doing little fun movements in
here so I think maybe just using this
like a screensaver for your TV
it'd be kind of fun to see the Pokemon
moving around in your house almost and
so once you've sent a Pokemon from
Pokemon go here to go park then how do
you bring it into the game the Pokemon
walk Arakawa Noble Park in the peninsula
Tony at all